Liam Grant ist konzentriert.
Es ist heute ein ganz besonderer Morgen,
denn am Freitag ist der Schulweg anders.
Da muss er nicht hinten bei der Mutter aufs
Fahrrad, sondern fährt mit seinem eigenen.
Der Vierjährige benutzt wie
Dutzende andere Kinder
den sogenannten „Bicibus“ hier in Barcelona:
eine organisierte Fahrradtour zur Schule.
Die Kinder lieben es.
Es gibt ihnen Unabhängigkeit.
Und es ist mal etwas anderes, etwas Neues.
Es ist wie eine Party auf Rädern –
mit Musik und Applaus für die Kleinen.
Sie haben die ganze Straße für sich,
dort, wo sonst Tausende Autos fahren,
vor denen sie Angst haben.
Das brauchen sie so nicht.
Jeden Freitag für etwa eine Stunde ist dieser
Weg zur Schule für Autos gesperrt.
So können die Kinder gefahrlos radeln.
Der „Bicibus“ ist ein Projekt, initiiert von
Eltern, die Veränderungen wollen.
Das ist die Idee,
diese Straße hier und künftig auch andere
Straßen in der Stadt zu befrieden.
Es gibt zwar Radwege,
aber vor allem für die kleinen
Kinder ist es noch schwierig,
in einer Fahrradspur geradeaus zu fahren.
Darüber hinaus fahren auch
viele Roller auf dem Radweg.
Und die Leute fahren oft sehr schnell.
Das ist für die Kleinen manchmal gefährlich.
Die Kinder genießen ihr Freitagsabenteuer.
Weil wir zusammen sind.
Und wir mögen es, Fahrrad zu fahren.
Es ist super, dass wir jetzt ohne Angst
auf der Straße fahren können.
Breitere, familienfreundliche Fahrradwege, die
vom Verkehr getrennt sind, kommen also.
Aber …
Auch wenn die Pläne in die richtige Richtung
gehen und die Stadtverwaltung
daran arbeitet, dauert es schon,
bis sich etwas ändert.
Bis dahin rollt die Party auf Rädern weiter –
mit immer mehr Kindern, die freitags
teilnehmen. Der „Bicibus“ kommt gut an.